>> Estelle Weyl: Hãy chuyển sang bộ chọn giao diện người dùng.
Vì vậy, trong HTML, bạn có thể có các phần tử được bật hoặc tắt,
bạn có thể có các phần tử được kiểm tra hoặc không được kiểm tra.
Vì vậy, ở đây nó nói, bất cứ ai có thể đọc điều này cho tôi?
Để tôi chỉ cho bạn cách bạn đọc nó, bạn đọc nó từ cuối.
Vậy nó ghi nhãn nào, dấu cộng nghĩa là gì?
>> Diễn giả 2: Ngay sau đây. >> Estelle Weyl: Ngay sau đây,
rất tốt.
Vì vậy, bất kỳ nhãn nào xuất hiện ngay sau hộp kiểm loại đầu vào đã chọn.
Vì vậy, ngay tại đây, chúng tôi có một hộp kiểm và chúng tôi có một nhãn, và chúng tôi có một hộp kiểm và
chúng tôi có một nhãn.
Vì vậy, nếu tôi chọn hộp kiểm này, màu sẽ chuyển thành màu đỏ.
Nếu tôi bỏ chọn nó, nó sẽ thay đổi trở lại, vì nó không còn được chọn nữa, điều tương tự ở đây.
Và bởi vì tôi đã suy nghĩ về khả năng tiếp cận và tôi đã đưa vào một nhãn,
Tôi không thực sự phải nhấp vào hộp kiểm.
Tôi có thể nhấp ngay vào đây trên nhãn và điều đó sẽ bật và tắt nó.
Vì vậy, đó là chuyển đổi hộp kiểm, sau đó sẽ kích hoạt CSS,
bởi vì điều này sau đó bắt đầu khớp.
Và khi tôi đã nói trước đó rằng CSS cập nhật ngay lập tức,
Tôi vừa cập nhật tính năng giao diện người dùng và CSS cho biết bây giờ tôi khớp, phải không.
>> Estelle Weyl: Vì vậy, các tính năng giao diện người dùng mà chúng tôi có là mặc định, hợp lệ, không hợp lệ,
bắt buộc, tùy chọn, trong phạm vi và ngoài phạm vi, chỉ đọc và đọc-ghi,
trình giữ chỗ được hiển thị và chúng tôi sẽ gặp lỗi do người dùng hoặc người dùng không hợp lệ.
Cả hai đều không được hỗ trợ ngay bây giờ, nó nằm trong thông số kỹ thuật, nó dường như đang thay đổi,
Tôi đọc cả hai tùy thuộc vào phiên bản nào.
Vì vậy, tôi không nói cho bạn biết nó sẽ là cái nào.
Vì vậy, trong biểu mẫu này ngay tại đây, chúng tôi có,
nếu hợp lệ, nó có đường viền màu xanh lục.
Nếu không hợp lệ, nó có đường viền màu đỏ.
Nếu nó được yêu cầu, thông qua thuộc tính bắt buộc hiện có,
aria-bắt buộc được đặt thành true, nó sẽ có đường viền 5px.
Nếu nó là tùy chọn, có nghĩa là nó không bắt buộc,
nó không có thuộc tính bắt buộc, đường viền sẽ là 10px.
Đúng, nếu nó nằm ngoài phạm vi, có nghĩa là,
trong ghi chú, nó nói từ 5 đến 7, có nghĩa là 5, 6 hoặc 7.
Số từ 0 đến 10 có nghĩa là 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Nó không có nghĩa là 5,2, nó không có nghĩa là 5,758.
Bởi vì trong HTML, khi bạn có một phạm vi, bạn có giá trị tối thiểu và tối đa, và ngay tại đây,
chúng tôi có tối thiểu và tối đa, có một thuộc tính bước mà chúng tôi đã không đưa vào.
Thuộc tính step mặc định là giá trị 1, nếu tôi đã nói bước bất kỳ,
thì nó sẽ là 5, 5.0001, cũng sẽ có giá trị.
Nhưng tôi đã không bao gồm bước, vì vậy nó được mặc định là giá trị 1.
>> Estelle Weyl: Trong bước thứ hai, tôi đặt bước 0,1.,
vì vậy 0,1 sẽ hợp lệ, 0,11 sẽ không hợp lệ.
>> Estelle Weyl: Đây, nó không hợp lệ vì nó được yêu cầu.
Chúng tôi thấy rằng nó là bắt buộc vì nó có 5px và tôi không có số trong đó.
Vì vậy, kết hợp bắt buộc của nó là true,
có đường viền 5px thay vì đường viền 10px.
Và bởi vì nó trống và nó không phải là tùy chọn, nó không hợp lệ.
Vì vậy, >> Estelle Weyl: Nếu tôi loại 4,
nó không hợp lệ và nằm ngoài phạm vi.
>> Estelle Weyl: Nếu tôi đặt 5, nó hợp lệ vì nó nằm trong phạm vi.
>> Estelle Weyl: Và nền trở thành màu xanh lục nhạt.
Khi không có giá trị, nó không bắt buộc, nó nằm trong phạm vi.
Vì vậy, ở đây, nếu tôi đặt -3, nó không hợp lệ.
>> Estelle Weyl: Nó trở nên hợp lệ nếu tôi làm 0,1, nó hợp lệ,
nếu tôi làm 0,15, nó không hợp lệ.
Vì vậy, đó là sự kết hợp giữa HTML và CSS mà bạn cần hiểu.
Vì vậy, một trong những điều thực sự quan trọng là phải hiểu
các thuộc tính mà bạn có.
Vì vậy, rất nhiều CSS mà chúng ta đã thấy cho đến nay chỉ dựa trên các bộ chọn và
các lớp học, đúng vậy, đó là những gì chúng tôi sử dụng hầu hết thời gian.
Nhưng nếu bạn hiểu HTML và tất cả các thuộc tính mà nó có,
bạn thực sự có thể làm cho CSS mạnh hơn nữa, bạn có một câu hỏi?
>> Người nói 3: Không hợp lệ diễn đạt điều kiện giống như không hợp lệ?
>> Estelle Weyl: Vâng.
>> Người nói 3: Được rồi.
>> Estelle Weyl: Và bạn biết không, chúng ta có thể kiểm tra nó, hãy kiểm tra lại.
>> Estelle Weyl: Vì vậy, ở đây tôi sẽ không.
>> Estelle Weyl: Vâng, vì vậy nếu bạn muốn chơi với nó chỉ trong một phút.
Được rồi, vì vậy khi tôi nói rằng CSS rất mạnh mẽ, nếu bạn đang ở trong trình bày và
bạn đang chơi với cái này, về cơ bản bạn đang chơi trên một trang khác.
Vì vậy, để di chuyển bộ bài về phía trước, chỉ cần nhấp vào bất kỳ nơi nào có màu hồng và
sau đó các mũi tên sẽ hoạt động trở lại.
Vì vậy, khi bạn ở đây và bạn đang chỉnh sửa nó,
mũi tên phải sẽ thực sự làm cho nó di chuyển sang phải, vì vậy nó không làm cho bộ bài bị vỡ.
Đúng vậy, bạn chỉ cần nhấp vào bất kỳ đâu và
sau đó bạn có thể tiến về phía trước một lần nữa, phải không?
>> Người thuyết trình 4: Địa chỉ email một, tôi tò mò về, vì khi bạn đang nhập,
bạn có thể đang nhập một địa chỉ email và nó có thể gây khó chịu cho
người dùng cuối thấy nó chuyển sang màu đỏ, có cách nào để giải quyết điều đó không?
>> Estelle Weyl: Bạn sẽ không làm cho nó chuyển sang màu đỏ, bạn thực sự sẽ làm điều này,
nó đang ở trên web.
Nhưng nó rất tinh vi, điều này thật đáng ghét, vì vậy một trong những điều chúng ta sẽ làm hôm nay
là, chúng tôi sẽ tạo ra những trang web thực sự xấu xí.
Và mục tiêu là, nếu bạn tạo một trang web xấu xí,
bạn sẽ không lo lắng về việc nó có đẹp hay không.
Vì vậy, điều này trông không đẹp, nhưng
nhà thiết kế giao diện người dùng của bạn sẽ đặt một con quay nhỏ trong khi nó không hợp lệ.
Và sau đó, yay, hãy đánh dấu kiểm khi nó hợp lệ.
Thứ gì đó ít đáng ghét hơn màu đỏ và xanh lá cây,
mà chúng ta không nên sử dụng màu sắc một mình.
Bởi vì một số người không thể nhìn thấy sự khác biệt giữa màu đỏ và màu xanh lá cây.
Vì vậy, bất cứ khi nào chúng ta làm ví dụ, ngày nay tốt hơn là làm cho mọi thứ trở nên xấu xí,
không đưa thứ xấu xí này vào sản xuất.
Và đây là một mẹo nhỏ tiện lợi mà bạn cũng không nên đưa vào sản xuất,
nhưng thật tuyệt khi bạn có thể làm được.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn nhìn thấy ở dưới cùng, nó cho biết, bạn không có mục nhập không hợp lệ.
>> Estelle Weyl: Đúng vậy, vì không cần thiết trong số này, vì vậy
điều này hoạt động với JavaScript.
Nhưng nếu tôi đặt số 8 và số 2 thì bây giờ tôi có 2 mục không hợp lệ.
Không có JavaScript trong trang này.
Những gì tôi đang làm là, tôi đang sử dụng bộ đếm CSS và
Tôi nghĩ chúng ta sẽ nói về bộ đếm CSS sau.
Nhưng về cơ bản mà nói, trên body, chúng tôi đặt bộ đếm thành 0.
Và sau đó mỗi khi bạn đánh thứ gì đó không hợp lệ, hãy tăng nó lên.
Và sau đó trong đoạn văn, hãy tạo nội dung nói rằng,
bạn có, bất kể Tài khoản không hợp lệ đó hiện tại là gì,
bộ đếm của Số tiền không hợp lệ, hãy in ra.
Và lý do mà nó phải đến sau, đúng, nó đến sau mọi thứ,
là bởi vì tôi phải thực sự có những mục nhập không hợp lệ đó để nó được tính.
Vì vậy, đoạn văn đó phải nằm sau những mục không hợp lệ đó.
Nếu không, nếu tôi đặt nó ở trên cùng, phải, nếu tôi làm,
cơ thể, >> Estelle Weyl: Nó sẽ không
có thể đếm.
Nếu tôi đã làm,
>> Estelle Weyl: liinth-of-type-2,
mà chúng ta sẽ đề cập sau, phải không,
nó sẽ chỉ có thể đếm cái đầu tiên.
Nếu tôi làm sau, hãy xem nó có hiệu quả không, tôi chưa bao giờ làm điều này trước đây.
Vâng, vì vậy bạn thực sự có thể đếm lỗi của mình.
Đây không phải là cách tốt nhất để làm công việc, đây không phải là phương pháp hay nhất.
Nhưng tôi muốn cho bạn thấy sức mạnh của CSS,
rằng bạn thực sự có thể làm tất cả mọi thứ nếu JavaScript của bạn không hoạt động.
Hoặc nếu bạn muốn cho một số người dùng biết họ có bao nhiêu lỗi thì biểu mẫu của họ không
điền vào và liên tục đếm, bạn thực sự có thể làm được điều đó.
Nâng cao lũy tiến, không bắt buộc phải có.